with music and [__] right man no I'm
just curious because I'm a big football
fan and I find it fascinating that like
you really like have like a real high
level like football run you know what
I'm saying before the rap [__] like took
off so yeah I just think it's fast but
obviously a part of your story so
I know it doesn't have anything to do
with what's going on right now
um I was gonna ask you like when it
comes to I remember when you signed with
Gotti and at that time I felt like there
was like a bidding war going on for estg
at that moment what made you rock with
Gotti and what is something over the
last two or three years that you have
learned I mean
well for the very first time in
bootlegia podcast history
we had someone walk off of the set